the Joe Rogan experience is there a
great record like a written record of
all of the origin stories like you were
talking to me about and all of the
various languages I mean it's all this
documented to make sure that we don't
lose this some better than others and a
lot of that is done there's no big text
that I can I can give you and share with
you that here's all all what you ever
needed to know about Indians that
doesn't exist I think probably should no
no I think that's up to the the Tribal
Nation to decide whether they want to
share that and and and and how to best
educate people about who they are and
that's what you know so many other
people have told our stories and have
taken down those histories and all those
people are telling the stories from a
Western perspective and none from not
having the cultural competent copied
competency and having lived and
implemented that way of life so it's
really dependent on on the tribes to
determine for themselves how they want
to put that forward there are many
tribes that actually have research
protocols that if you want to do you
want to study you want to research you
have to get authority from the Tribal
Nation to do that and and they have to
have a say in whether it was done
appropriately so again it's back to us
telling our own stories us being part of
our own narratives and us being part of
the decision-making that affects us I
respect and appreciate that 100% what I
meant was inside the tribe is there a
documented version of all these stories
and of the language so that can be
passed down I think the real concern
seems to be when you're
talk about these incredibly impoverished
communities there the real concern is
that some of these stories may be lost
or some of these some of the language
may even be lost there I think it varies
like I said there's 574 federally
recognized tribes and 300 other tribal
groups let me tell you the story about
the chittim Aceh who are in Louisiana
like just surrounded by marshes right
there in the Gulf of Mexico
their last language speaker died in the
1940s and even though they had you know
language speakers around them
none of those languages were related to
theirs their language was more closely
connected with peoples in in Mesoamerica
so obviously there was a trade there was
a relationship between who the chittim
aceh are and were with people from mezzo
and south america yeah I mean there's
there's amazing histories and stories
out there but but what happened with
their languages is in 80's and 90's the
Smithsonian had all these wax cylinders
of tribal languages and songs and dances
and they started repatriating those back
to different tribal nations so when the
chittim Aceh got these wax cylinders
they're like whoa we have a
responsibility here we have to do
something with this and so they pulled
their community together and everyone
everyone you know got their grandmas and
their auntie's and everyone to pull
together words that they knew two
stories that they knew different
cultural practices and building and and
crafting and all of those things pulled
all that together with the wax cylinders
they got some money from rosetta stone
and create recreated their language that
had been lost and today in their schools
and their tribal Lee run schools
they speak their language those children
are speaking their language from
kindergarten up so an incredible success
story now they were able to do that
because they had gaming revenue to help
support that and when you go to the
school and when you hear the story about
how that happened it's it's it's
incredible so there are stories like
that among all tribes of how they've
been able to recover from what was lost
and so it's it's a long process to
correct what has happened but there are
warriors all over Indian country and
that's that's what they're doing every
day is is trying to recover what was
lost well that's a great success story
and it's beautiful to hear I I just hope
that that can continue with all the
different stories it's just when you
read books about Native American culture
and you just get sort of the like the
most surface taste of what it must have
been like it seems like there's this
incredibly rich history that could could
be lost in time mm-hmm and that would be
a horrible horrible shame it's right
here in front of us and it's it's here
right now and the fact that someone like
you worked so hard to get this message
out here and to let people know what
what is actually happening and the the
plight of these American Indians and the
tribes and what they're still going
through today and that this is not a
battle that happened in the 1800s this
is a battle that's happening today right
every day every day
[Applause]